hey this is so bizarre I can't believe
I'm doing this story Japanese Prime
Minister Shinzo ABI visited the White
House and met with Donald Trump at the
start of the weekend they did the
typical thing where they come out at the
White House to these matching podiums
they give some remarks Shinzo Abby spoke
Japanese and you might recall that
typically when you've got a visiting
world leader who speaks a language other
than English the US president will wear
an earpiece as do members of the media
sitting in the crowd so that they can
understand what on earth is being
discussed because they may not speak the
language of the visiting dignitary or
world leader you might know where I'm
going with this
numerous reporters noticed that Donald
Trump was not wearing an earpiece for a
whole bunch of Shinzo Abbey's comments
and Rebecca ball house The Wall Street
Journal's White House reporter sent out
a tweet with a picture saying Trump does
not appear to be wearing an earpiece to
translate Prime Minister Ivy's remarks
then we saw a tweet from William Edwards
who's the AFP news agency's video
correspondent saying our White House
correspondent points out Trump doesn't
seem to have a translation earpiece
isn't listening to a word obvious saying
now here's the clincher and this is just
rich Trump was nodding along while
Shinzo Abby was speaking as if he
understood Japanese even though
obviously he couldn't understand the
word of what was being said I'm gonna
play a little video and audio for you
we're going to be able to hear the live
translation but the key thing is Trump
can't hear this he doesn't have an
earpiece in but look at him not along
pretending like he understands Japanese
for me to visit the United States the
last time was in Pearl Harbor Hawaii at
the end of nasty at all indeed sincerely
grateful a for the always heartwarming
welcome accorded to you by the American
people I would also like to express my
sincere gratitude the president Truong
Oh Donald you must have been
check out this hilarious report from CNN
about this president was standing there
but not able to understand likely what
the Prime Minister was saying because he
did not have his translator earpiece in
several members of his staff and the
vice president didn't either it wasn't
until after that after the questions got
going that they seemed to realize that
they had these translator devices here
so the president was laughing at the
jokes at the beginning about golf and
other things but he seemed to be
following the cues of
some advisors who had these earpieces in
but after you know the accession who
went on he did put hairs in I love how
the CNN reporter gives him every benefit
of the doubt and says well I don't think
he likely would have been able to
understand what Shinzo Abe a was saying
as if there's a chance maybe Donald
Trump understands Japanese yeah there's
a chance Trump was understanding what
Shinzo ABI was saying at some point
after the opening remarks were done
Trump noticed that there was an earpiece
on his podium and realized what it was
there for so some people might laugh
this off but this relates once again to
the consistent growing narrative that we
have about Trump in his relationship to
the presidency in the rest of the world
Donald Trump doesn't care what Shinzo
ABI says and it makes no difference to
Trump what Shinzo ABI says and it also
speaks to the constant lack of
preparation on every level from Trump's
team Trump didn't realize he would need
an earpiece nobody on Trump's team told
him to put the earpiece on he ignored an
earpiece sitting on the podium in front
of him if I were meeting with a foreign
head of state who spoke no English one
of my first questions would be how do I
communicate and if I were not that
Shinzo obby speaks no English but
hypothetically even if you came to me
and you said hey David you're going to
meet with Angela Merkel my first
question would be what's her English
proficiency or will I need a translator
and in what language will different
parts of the event it take place here I
found one silver lining though Pat when
I read the headline it crossed my mind
that Trump may have actually mimicked a
Japanese sounding sort of way of
speaking which would have been insanely
offensive so I was sort of relieved that
Trump merely pretended to understand
Japanese and didn't do the hugely
offensive just sort of like speaking
words that sound Japanese like because
that would have been more embarrassing
right so I'm not gonna defend him for
for not choosing to wear the earpiece
but smiling and going along with it I
think that's okay because there are
other kind of nonverbal cues where you
can kind of understand what someone's
saying so I probably got the sense that
whatever Shinzo Abe a was saying it was
positive right there as as we heard
during the CNN report Trump was clearly
using visual cues in order to know when
to not along but the point is he wasn't
understanding a word of what Shinzo ABI
was saying and he seemed it not really
that bothered by it he seemed perfectly
calm just standing up there nodding
along without knowing what was being
said by the leader of another country I
remember a scene very similar to this
played by Leslie Nielsen in one of the
Naked Gun movies this is just so
embarrassing for the United States
please take the David Pakman show
audience survey at david pakman.com
slash survey gathering information about
what the audience likes doesn't like and
what you guys want on upcoming program
so please check it out david pakman.com
slash survey i'm on twitter at d Pakman
we'll take a break and be back after
this